{\rtf1\ansi\ansicpg1252\cocoartf1038\cocoasubrtf360
\margl1440\margr1440\vieww10200\viewh10960\viewkind0
\pard\tx720\tx1440\tx2160\tx2880\tx3600\tx4320\tx5040\tx5760\tx6480\tx7200\tx7920\tx8640\ql\qnatural
\f0\fs24 \cf0 Here is what we have to do.\'a0
The fiscal cliff everybody complains about
- and there will be some pain associated with
it, is a 1.3% recessionary economy for two
quarters. What you can't do is fix the deficit
by cutting taxes for millionaires and then
taking money away from people on social security
and Medicare.\'a0 That's what the Republicans
want to do.\
The reason I like the idea of going over the
fiscal cliff is this is an incredibly partisan
congress, which has accomplished essentially
nothing in the last two years since the republicans
have taken over.\'a0 And they're not going
to come up with a better solution and here
is what is good about the fiscal cliff.\'a0
First of all, we go back to the tax rate when
Clinton was president.\'a0 We had a much better
economy.\'a0 We had a\'97the last balanced
budget we had was under Clinton.\'a0 Republicans
do not balance budgets.\'a0 I have no idea.\'a0
I think Eisenhower was the last budget that
was balanced under a Republican.\'a0 You can't
trust them with your money.\
So what you need to do is increase the taxes
to where they were when Bill Clinton was president
of the United States and you need to cut defense.\'a0
It has never been cut because every defense
although the defense establishment has plants
in 420 out of the 435 congressional districts.\'a0
That won't be done unless we drive over the
fiscal cliff.\'a0 I as a Democrat am willing
to sacrifice the cuts that we're going to
have to make in the programs we care about
in order to get those two things done, otherwise,
they will not be done. And it is so craven
of the congress to be scrambling around trying
to figure out how to get out the agreement
that they made because they're feathering
in their own nest. \'a0 I'm tired of having
politicians that won't do the tough stuff.\'a0
Yes, it's going to be unpleasant.\'a0 We spent
a lot of money that we didn't have.\'a0 Now
we're going to have to pay the bill.\'a0 If
we don't pay it now we really are going to
end up like Greece.\'a0 I don't want that
to happen and I do not trust the Republicans
because they're terribly fiscally irresponsible
and frankly, I don't trust the Democrats a
lot either, even though they have a much better
record on fiscal matters because it was Clinton
and Gore that balanced the last budget.\
So I think we ought to go over the cliff.\'a0
We ought to bite the bullet.\'a0 It will take
7 \'bd trillion dollars out of our deficit.\'a0
That's a big number and there will be sacrifices,
but any politician who tells the American
people there aren't going to be any sacrifices
for everybody is a liar and I do not want
the sacrifices to be on the backs of the middle
class.\'a0 I think it's time the people who
made all that money screwing up the banking
system paid their fair share.\'a0\
}